what you're looking at is a clam's
foot
that's right clams have a foot
and some species can extend it several
inches but as it turns out a foot is
just one of the many bizarre features
you'll find inside a clam
like oysters and mussels clams are
bi-valves a kind of mollusk that's
encased in a shell made of two valves or
hinging parts and that shell comes in
all different sizes there are small
clams like these which are often used
for cooking and then there are giant
clams which can grow more than a meter
long and weigh as much as 250 kilograms
but no matter their size clams have some
truly bizarre stuff going on inside
and to get a closer look we went
clamming
oh god
that's marine biologist soren dahl who
took us clamming on long island
at first we didn't have much luck i got
one but it looks like it's dead
oh old shell oh i got a crab
then we stumbled upon what's known as a
honey hole it's basically a clamors code
word for jackpot hey i got two all right
and in the end we found about a dozen
hard clams this right here is my
recently collected
my recently collected clams and i have
a lot of them
now to see what's inside you can't
exactly pry one open with your bare
hands and that's thanks to these two
muscles they run from the inside of one
shell to the other and when clams sense
a threat or find themselves out of water
they contract
causing the clam to
you know
clam up so to get one open you need to
cut through those muscles now you have
your
this is your hard shell clamp both of so
that those two muscles together create a
muscle that goes from here to here yep
this this goes from this side to that
side
and what about that strange foot this is
the foot right here
so it might not be as impressive as this
but that's just because here the foot is
retracted and they'll extend this out of
the clam and they can push themselves
along the bottom and use it to dig a
hole
to help bring themselves into like a
burrow and some clams are particularly
dexterous with their foot the razor clam
for example can bury itself 70
centimeters underground it uses rapid
movements of its foot to fluidize the
ground around it essentially turning it
into quicksand but if you think clam
feet are bizarre check out this thing
the siphon siphons are essentially two
connected straws that clams stick out of
their shells
one pulls in water which contains food
particles and oxygen and the other
expels waste
and none is more impressive than the one
belonging to the gooey duck clam
it's so big the clam can't even close
its shell while siphons allow clams to
eat and breathe some clams have another
more advanced tactic for getting
nutrients
instead of just sucking food out of the
water giant clams farm it themselves
like coral they have a symbiotic
relationship with microalgae the clams
provide algae with a place to live and
photosynthesize
and in exchange algae gives the clam
byproducts of photosynthesis such as
sugars which enables the giant clams to
grow you know giant now on rare
occasions there's something else you
might find inside a clam a pearl
that's right oysters aren't the only
pearl producers out there clams too will
form these shimmering clumps to trap
irritants that enter their shells in
fact a fisherman once found a 34
kilogram pearl inside a giant clam so
yeah clams aren't just fascinating they
might also be precious
plus they actually play an important
role in their environment by sucking up
particles to eat they function like
natural water filters making marshes
lakes and other habitats more livable
and on top of that they're delicious to
eat
not to mention
really fun to collect